The Walking Dead boasts one of the biggest
casts on TV. As a result, it's enjoyed a
whole lot of unique cameos -- so many, in fact,
that you might not have noticed most of them.
These are the most surprising, interesting, and
just plain strange cameos on The Walking Dead.
Hines Ward was among the NFL's most athletic,
dazzling, and accomplished wide receivers in the
late 1990s and 2000s. In his 14-season career,
spent entirely with the Pittsburgh Steelers,
he managed 1,000 successful receptions,
placing him high on the all-time list,
which led to four Pro Bowl
selections and two Super Bowl rings.
Ward was drafted out of the University of
Georgia, where one of his teammates on the
gridiron was running back IronE Singleton,
who pursued acting upon graduation.
Singleton found success in Hollywood, landing
roles in movies like Remember the Titans,
The Blind Side, and The Longest Yard – and
eventually, on the first three seasons of
The Walking Dead, in which he portrayed zombie
apocalypse survivor Theodore Douglas, AKA T-Dog.
In 2012, Ward utilized his connection to Singleton
to land a small role on The Walking Dead as well,
which was then shooting in
his home state of Georgia.
When the show's location moved
to a semi-abandoned prison,
Ward got to play one of the zombies who pounce
on the main survivor characters. Ward spent two
hours in makeup to be transformed into a walker,
where an artist painted his old jersey number, 86,
onto the back of his head. Even as a stumbling
zombie, we wouldn't want to go up against him.
Before The Walking Dead hit AMC in
2010 and produced some of the best
viewership numbers in cable TV history, zombie
entertainment was primarily seen as niche fare,
enjoyed by only a relatively small segment of the
population. Sure, everyone knew what zombies were,
but only dedicated fans could offer opinions
on Night of the Living Dead or discuss the
finer points of Re-Animator. Zombies were,
in other words, for nerds — but then those
much-maligned individuals enjoyed
a big moment in the early 2010s.
Comedian Chris Hardwick, an avowed nerd, had
just launched his popular Nerdist podcast,
the first brick in a media empire that caters
to, well, unabashed nerds like himself.
When The Walking Dead returned for its
highly anticipated second season in 2011,
new episodes were followed by a new series:
Talking Dead. On Talking Dead, cast and crew
from The Walking Dead and special celebrity guests
gather to talk about the episode that just aired.
The whole endeavor is hosted by the always
enthusiastic and proudly nerdy Hardwick.
"Holy shit!"
Those two shows collided, and Hardwick
earned himself a major thrill,
when, in 2019, the Nerdist founder made a
brief, hard-to-spot appearance on The Walking
Dead. Near the end of the episode "Scars," a
walker tries to attack Judith. That zombie is
none other than Hardwick, who achieved, in
that moment, the peak of zombie nerd-dom.
Anthrax's Scott Ian is one of a rare breed: the
most famous member of a band, even though he isn't
the lead singer. Since the 1980s, Ian has played
guitar in the legendary thrash metal group,
and has perpetually overshadowed the group's
various singers. He sports a memorable look,
what with his shaved head and long, pointy wizard
beard. Ian is also a big fan of horror media,
and once hosted a web series called Bloodworks,
where he explored how gore effects are made.
"It's 5:15 or something in the
morning here in Atlanta, and
we're on the set of The Walking Dead."
All these unique qualities, along with
his friendship with Walking Dead special
effects makeup designer Greg Nicotero, helped
land Ian a gig on cable's top zombie show.
In 2011, Ian was rendered unrecognizable
by a thick slathering of gore and makeup
effects in his appearance as a walker
on a webisode of The Walking Dead.
He returned to the franchise
in the 2015 episode "Remember":
His anonymous zombie hides under a trash
heap and reaches out to grab the leg of
an unsuspecting Rick Grimes, but is quickly
stopped when the sheriff allows his son, Carl,
to shove a metal pole through the undead Ian's
head, instantly dispatching him. What a gory way
to go — but then again, we're not sure this
horror hound would be happy with anything less.
Sam Witwer has done voice work for the Star
Wars universe, held the major role of Davis
Bloome for a season of the Superman-centric
series Smallville, played vampire Aidan Waite
on four seasons of Being Human, and portrayed
Mr. Hyde, of horror legend, on Once Upon a Time.
Nearly a decade into his bustling career as an
actor in both film and TV, Witwer took a role
on the first episode of The Walking Dead – one
with no lines and scant screen time. The part:
"Tank Soldier," a zombified ex-military man
that Rick Grimes has to kill in Atlanta.
Witwer was supposed to return to the show
later on, as showrunner Frank Darabont
wanted to produce some prequel episodes
about the fall of Atlanta to zombies.
As originally planned, Witwer would have
reportedly had a more robust role playing
that soldier before his zombification, but
unfortunately, those episodes never came to pass.
Most television viewers and filmgoers might
not know M.C. Gainey by name, but they
certainly recognize his face. The prolific
character actor has appeared in nearly 200
projects, usually in small but pivotal roles, and
typically as a villain. Gainey plays angry guys,
corrupt authority figures,
violent criminals, and the like:
His impressive resume includes roles like Big John
Brittle in Django Unchained, Tom Friendly on Lost,
and Poppa Poutine on Riverdale. If a
character played by Gainey shows up,
it generally means very bad news for the film or
TV series' protagonist. Gainey told The Junction,
"With a face like this, there aren't a lot
of lawyers or priest roles coming my way."
It's true: Gainey's mug is a craggy marvel that
was made to loom menacingly out of the shadows.
Audiences are likely to be most familiar with
Gainey for his work as Swamp Thing in Con Air,
or perhaps Bo Crowder on Justified, but probably
not at all from his time on The Walking Dead.
He appeared just once on The Walking Dead, In the
2014 episode "Slabtown," his recognizable face
heavily obscured by thick makeup so he
could amble around as an anonymous zombie.
In 2002, Keisha Castle-Hughes
enjoyed what is probably the
best response an actor can get for their
debut performance. At just 12 years old,
the Australian-born actress starred in the
highly acclaimed New Zealand-produced film
Whale Rider, for which she earned an Academy
Award nomination for Best Actress. She was,
at the time, the youngest person to
ever be recognized in that category.
She then re-emerged in 2015 as the fierce
Dornish warrior Obara Sand on Game of Thrones.
Just before she joined the cast of that
megawatt HBO series, Castle-Hughes
booked a spot on The Walking Dead.
In the 2014 episode "Slabtown," she portrayed
Joan, a zombie outbreak survivor held prisoner
by Gorman. Bitten by a walker during an escape
attempt, she endures a grueling arm amputation,
but ultimately takes her own life by opening
her stitches and allowing herself to bleed out.
Joan then reanimates as a zombie,
and is killed by Dawn Lerner.
Though The Walking Dead's ratings
figures had fallen off from the
stratospheric levels the show once reached
at its peak, it still remained one of the
most popular and high-profile shows on
cable TV by the time 2019 rolled around.
All throughout the series' run, it's
been a lucrative gig for actors.
Landing a role on the show can serve
as marvelous exposure for any actor,
even one who has already established themselves
on other well-known television series -- and
even if you're just there for a one-off
role to show up, zombie out, and get shot.
That's very much the case for Rutina Wesley,
who first found fame as Tara Thornton on HBO's
lauded vampire saga, True Blood. After her time
on that show ended in 2014, Wesley enjoyed a
long arc on NBC's Hannibal as Reba McClane,
as well as a couple of guest spots on the CW's
flagship DC superhero series, Arrow. In 2016, she
began starring as Nova Bordelon on the celebrated
Oprah Winfrey Network family drama, Queen Sugar.
One truth emerges from Wesley's
filmography: She's busy, flexible,
and just as comfortable portraying the nuances of
bereavement as she is hanging out with vampires.
Despite her packed schedule, Wesley
found time to appear on a single
episode of The Walking Dead in 2019. In
"Scars," Wesley portrayed Jocelyn, or
Joss, a cruel and controlling leader of a
cult-like collective of children. Michonne,
her old friend from before the end of the world
arrived, is forced to end her wicked ways.
In addition to The Walking Dead
comics series writer Robert Kirkman
and the TV series developer Frank
Darabont, the one person who has had
the biggest behind-the-scenes impact on the
long-running zombie show is Greg Nicotero.
He's directed more than 30 episodes,
served as various types of producer,
and heads up the show's special effects
make-up department — which means he's
responsible for turning groups of actors into
monstrously flesh-dripping zombie hordes.
To say he's an integral part of the
show is a massive understatement.
Every now and then, Nicotero even gets in on
the fun, taking a spin in the zombification
chair himself. Between 2010 and 2016,
Nicotero appeared in five episodes,
each time as an undead walker. His Walking Dead
colleagues tend to grant him some of the most
plum zombie assignments available. In one
appearance set in the town of Woodbury,
for example, he was tasked with lunging at Andrea,
who stops him with a pistol blast to the head.
"This is my friend. This is Greg Nicotero."
A TV adaptation of The Walking Dead might look
and feel completely different if not for the work
of Charlie Adlard. In 2004, Adlard joined the
creative staff of the comic series upon which
the show is based as a penciler. From there on,
he helped bring the stories of Robert Kirkman
and his other collaborators to life,
until its final issue hit stands in 2019.
When you think of The Walking Dead
comic, what you picture is Adlard's work.
His vision of the apocalypse, full of
dark, inky shadows and weathered faces,
is a terrifying triumph of comics art,
to say nothing of the fact that it
formed the foundation of what became
one of the most popular shows on TV.
Appropriately enough, Adlard got to be
part of the TV world he helped to realize.
During production of the show's first season in
the summer of 2010, he reported to the set of The
Walking Dead to spend three days filming a cameo
appearance as a walker. As he later recounted
in an interview with comicbookmovie.com, it
was a thrilling experience. As he recalled,
"Three days of seeing my creations come
to life ... I felt very privileged."
Adlard can be seen amongst the horde
of walkers that attacks a very confused
Sheriff Rick Grimes in Atlanta in "Days Gone
By," the very first episode of The Walking Dead.
After building up a reputation as a versatile
actor and something of a muse for filmmaker Tim
Burton in quirky classics like Ed Wood,
Edward Scissorhands, and Sleepy Hollow,
Johnny Depp became one of the biggest movie
stars in the world in the 21st century.
He's starred as Captain Jack Sparrow in
five enormously successful Pirates of
the Caribbean movies, as the Mad Hatter in
two Alice in Wonderland adventures, and as
Gellert Grindelwald in the Harry Potter prequel
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald.
In 2016, Depp even made time for a brief guest
star appearance on an episode of The Walking Dead
... or at least part of him did, and apparently
without his knowledge or active participation.
In the episode "Not Tomorrow Yet," a decapitated
human head makes an appearance that bears a
strong resemblance to Depp. According
to makeup and effects wizard and
"Not Tomorrow Yet" director Greg Nicotero, that's
because the head is, in fact, Johnny Depp's head.
Nicotero told Entertainment Weekly,
"I think we had sculpted an emaciated
version of a dummy head for something
and we used Johnny Depp's head as
a basis just for a clay sculpt."
That's certainly one way of making an appearance.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.